[Música]
[Aplausos]
ustedes saben cuántas morante ambiente
para los entrenamientos
8 5 10 20
bueno eso depende del evento
extraordinario
cuando mejoras
lineal
la danza a través del tiempo se ha visto
se ha sido visto como algo que las niñas
y desapareciendo honduras lastimosamente
se ha quedado atrás
[Música]
y tenemos un aproximado de 1500 eso
corresponde sobre el 1 por ciento de la
cifra de los peregrinos
para mí
entonces pero cuáles creen que es la
causa de lo que pasa esto
pues la pieza machista
cuáles creen que serán las causas
[Música]
pues los comentarios que dicen que no
hay peros inútil debería de hacer otra
cosa debe terminar
estos son sólo algunos de los muchos
comentarios que no mencionan sólo
digamos el 0.1
entonces
todo eso en el problema de no saber todo
el trabajo que nosotros hacemos porque
otra vez ha terminado
lo curioso es que el mundo en fin ha
terminado como algo que no es aceptable
o que está mal o que no se debe pasar lo
curioso es que la danza es algo que
acepta todo
[Música]
millones
lanza tu puede ser quien quiera hacer
sin sepultar
y
hay cosas que
una vez que tienes
y eso
no pueden hacer otras cosas
y ese día llegó a mi casa y ahora
superan en entrenaron los potentes arias
o se tiene que aprender una hora
completa
y es alrededor de los mismos miembros
ansa
una clase de
qué
lasa
también lo ven como algo que no podemos
llegar
es una carretada entonces yo no tengo la
facilidad económica
s
[Música]
e
y como tienen emociones y
todo
y todo eso
invocar
me dice
le pregunté yo no siento que necesite
simpatía nada más
como ha sido la persona que me sigue
quiere decir
él siempre está allí y le diré que tus
padres
completamente
dos días más tarde
[Música]
pero
los demás decían
[Música]
para mí creo que estas son las
principales
una de las causas podría ser que eso es
poco aprovechamiento de decisiones
artísticas tiene
y no aprovechar la transforma
en mejorar la visión a largo plazo el
gnomo
no tener la precisión o dirección que la
del diente tener
y pensar como instituciones
cómo utilizar una institución del
extranjero que podría apoyar el próximo
artístico de las instituciones también
podría crear el fondo dentro de la
institución que soporte a los
extranjeros
cuando regresen contribuimos de esa
participa la institución mejorar la
proyección de la institución de opción
de comunicación revistas periódicos
pérez sociales todas las públicas
porque siempre digo si la persona no
puede llegar adelante es tarde
entonces nos lleva en la maleta
después de una presentación
la sorpresa es solamente el estado
otra del entorno y creo que el que más
afecta a nosotros son las normas
adicionales
en honduras las normas son bien marcadas
entonces
según la organización de la salud
como la
en la exigencia de los comportamientos
como los de los otros por el
comportamiento
veo
en familia
por qué
otros son los pensamientos de grandes
propinas que si bien el ballet del
cepillo
donde sea
y el fenómeno que pasa en la esperanza
que hay en varones que entran en
escuelas alrededor
[Música]
quiere que venga
me salí por el tiempo tiene que decir
por qué no
o me van muy bien por eso
[Música]
entonces
si tiene un hermano amigo conocido
de signo
dos días antes de tiempo
vamos a versiones de información
cuáles son tus presentaciones para
nosotros
a
veréis
una pregunta que es extrema todas las
mañanas
antes el portero cuando pasen las horas
le dije porque hay sólo 15
la idea de por qué hay salud
este es sólo uno de los muchos
comentarios
[Música]
s cuando la gran maría pero nosotros nos
vamos a rendir hasta negarse a nuestra
estable
ar
y tratar de educar a las personas
compartir y demostrar que nosotros
estamos en una estación
y
y el cual es esporádico como la idea de
que
[Música]
artística
arte para todos los que se estudia de
ésta
cambiar este des pensamiento que dice
venga antes
de esta manera de cambiar esta idea de
los manos
esta manera de esta organización que
soporte a las instituciones artísticas
es como yo quiero
[Aplausos]